je les milieux sportifs on attendait ce
soir la décision de la fédération
française de football quant au report ou
à l'annulation du match bastia marseille
comptant pour les demi finales de la
coupe de france les avis vous le savez
sont partagés papin pense qu'il ne faut
pas jouer le match les joueurs de bastia
sont abattus ils ne veulent pas revenir
semble-t-il sur le terrain michel
platini s'interroge apparemment on ne
sera fixé que demain les réactions
recueillies par olivier rey la
fédération française de football n'a
toujours pas pris de décision sur la
poursuite de l'épreuve
en tout cas pour les joueurs bastiais
marseillais il serait préférable par
respect pour les victimes de furiani de
ne pas rejouer tout d'un coup j'ai cru
que le public faisait une rolls a mais
c'était pas la ola puisque la tribune
disparaît scène et je voyais plus les
gens remonter et là il ya eu pas du tout
de mouvement de panique parce que les
gens même les gens qui étaient devant
était surpris ils n'ont pas entendu de
cris rien du tout bon nous les joueurs
de sucre s'est précipité au niveau du
grillage pour commencer à défaire les
pour que les gens puissent rentrer sur
le terrain et puis aller voir un peu ce
qui se passait de l'autre côté il faudra
pas du tout pensé à essayer de jouer ce
match
nous on a déjà pas du tout l'esprit à
jouer quoi un match comme ça presque
jouer après le drame qui a eu je crois
qu'il faut respecter ceux qui sont
tombés et aux moines ne pas jouer pour
leur mémoire
on est solidaire du drame qu'ils vivent
surtout les familles je crois qu'il faut
surtout penser aux familles pas sous mon
choix final qu'on la joue pas je pensais
pas forcément très important mais à des
gens qui souffrent et des gens
comprenaient très bien gérard on vous
retrouve en direct de bastia j'ai bien
écouté les joueurs ce midi dans le
journal j'ai l'impression qu'ils n'ont
pas vraiment envie de jouer cette demi
finale
tous les joueurs que j'ai pu rencontrer
aujourd'hui me le disait on n'a pas
envie on est un peu dégoûté on est
choqué il ya eu une réunion cet
après-midi des joueurs je ne sais pas ce
qu'il en est sorti parce qu'il devait y
avoir une conférence de presse du
président filippi le président de bastia
là à 19h30 elle s'est pas tenu cette
conférence
claude est marquée en revient il ya un
des dirigeants lui a dit il est fort
possible qu'on soit forfait c'est à dire
qu'on se retire de la coupe de france et
dans ce cas là ce serait marseille qui
serait qualifié pour la finale
on dirait même que la recette à ce
moment là c'est peut-être remercier
reversés aux victimes de cet accident
et puis c'est vrai qu'on se pose aussi
la question de savoir ce que va devenir
ce lieu de fête
ce lieu de liesse qui était fort yani et
qui est devenu hier un lieu de mort
et un lieu de martyrs on peut dire henry
juste pour se quitter comme ça que
c'était exactement il ya 24 heures pile
l'accident et ce soir je pense que même
quelques secondes de silence en
regardant cette épouvantable décor
serait pas malvenu
merci gérard l'eau